oh my god is that the reject nation John
stay over there
it's the reject nation people I'm Greg
Alba your host for today's specialty
this is Brian Garcia she has a YouTube
channel called her name but she has a
segment on there called talk about it
she hit me up she interviewed me it was
a fun interview we had some delicious
African tacos that's right I didn't even
know those existed north african tacos
will let us be clear almost got in
trouble that day yeah that footage did
not make it in a really fun time any ho
guys I have her here with me today we
watched a couple of other videos but I
know what you guys really want you guys
want to try not to laugh challenge
I was hoping we're gonna do this here's
how simple this is you don't laugh you
sincerely try not to you sincerely try
not to the idea is this is supposed to
be the most hilarious thing compilation
in the world this is number 29 I hate it
the one good man by the way I get pretty
anal about like trying not to smile
either you know do you really yeah
smiling you can get away with it just
don't go like you're just laying your
eyes oh oh you win nothing but my
respect and if you fail just keep going
it's really not a competition I feel
like there's something else I'm missing
yeah just don't laugh oh yeah oh that's
the other big career rap hey do people
do that it'll be his last one that's
probably because they're never monetized
last one was last try not to laugh
challenge it's the second or last one
[Music]
man sad day
[Music]
[Music]
two of us
[Music]
that can't be real
that is so staged that's not a real
situation
let's do first
[Music]
[ __ ] me
[Music]
what is this shower [ __ ] playing well
what is this this this this or anything
ten delicious items on Taco Bell's new
tower morning value menu each for just a
buck looks too good right now the new
value no no yeah watch the Penguins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like other stranded turtle
turtles wait I've seen my animal lovers
look how she put the little guy back in
the water as a hobby and by the way that
turtle was actually a tortoise and
tortoises
backfired so badly
did you know David
[Music]
so what's the kinkiest thing either one
of you is ever done and I'll meet this
little white chick right so next no I
get in their ear man and she lets me
take her back to my spot and she did we
in a sports its own nor will I ever be
three senses later I use the restroom
because I am a woman I changed my gender
I'm a nurse to female because I there's
a little cannot for me what's wrong with
that well yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I can't believe you've done this
[Music]
what would you do you ever see that if
there was a child right in front of you
[Music]
based on whether a boy or a girl
the legal status how you express
yourself and identify yourself is he
gonna poo it's gonna poop that's scared
me a dick
and if that was funny a dick why are you
going why are you going that's such a
dark start to your try not to laugh
challenge I want you to know that by the
way as I spent the first like 15 seconds
I was going to well why do second a lot
hi I know of him pretty well I've known
her for years and like we've chatted
here and there I've never met up in
person maybe maybe I got to find out
what's really going on here whatever BS
story he tells you I'll tell you guys
the truth
I wonder what's going on maybe something
I feel like I can do is speculate now
something to do with the ad pocalypse
there's a lot but I know that try not to
laugh challenges are not videos that can
get monetized usually because it's a lot
of different types of content and the
music and stuff really gets you every
time we try not to laughs here they're
never monetized it has to be so much
work into editing I imagine so oh yeah
yeah you know what really got me the one
with the two black guys oh you didn't
like the part with the black guys really
takes a hiatus yeah he's just taking
this he's pulling a fought but it says
he's breaking up yeah but then years
later years later he comes back with a
church that's what I compose over the
years the funniest you will laugh I
guarantee honestly I've seen a lot of
try not to laugh challenges and there
are some are just I've never even put up
on YouTube I just think this is just
boring if this is so easy to not laugh
at but he knows this is his sense of
humors for the most part pretty on par
with what makes me laugh that story that
the first couple you know they look the
kinkiest thing you've done that's like
every guy's work that's why it got me I
really thought it was like a real thing
and then they don't I was like yeah oh
right when she was like I don't want to
say and he's like come on BAE I'm like
okay that punchlines gonna come back
yeah yeah that's a terrifying situation
for any guy to be in to find out the
girl you're with
well in some ways yeah yeah oh my god
I've never actually dated a girl who's
I've met many a woman who have said once
you go black you never go back
that is quotes from many women I've met
stay true to that
yeah there's actually just can't change
yeah and that's why cuz it's
intimidating because I probably I think
you're sure Oh totally yeah yeah that's
that's a whole arena you know have you
dated a black damn but you you've you've
gone back to other no beyond that just
just anyone who were reviewing trailers
not today if I was dating a girl I was
seriously and heavily involved in that
fact she's done kinkier stuff with
another guy yeah that would kind of mess
with me a little bit actually a hell of
a lot that's I'm totally bullshitting it
yeah I would have mess with me a lot
yeah why because you feel like she's had
a certain relationship with other people
who and like that you are so
inexperienced in comparison
oh no well I guess it's one thing if
I've never done it and then she's done
it but if it's something I'm I've done
before but she just won't do with me
okay give me a minor example I should
definitely text her to see if it's okay
put this in the video my girlfriend once
sent like ten years ago you say was the
current one okay no would never have
been known a girl that I've dated that
is interesting like 10 years ago sent up
sent a photo of her breasticles
to a man
can she refuses to send one to me like
refused and I'm like I would love that
why not she eventually did like months
later just something like dad like I
don't know remember this is a cliche Oh
girls get emotionally jealous and guys
get physically jealous you know yeah I'd
say so
I'm sure you get both you can't just
hand out pictures like that especially
if you're trying to pursue acting or
something imagine she's not okay but I'm
just saying she has a more important for
you anyway a dick
I appreciate that Mariah and I were able
to discuss that based off 30 seconds of
footage in your 8 minute and 50 seconds
we'll get some talk about it guys listen
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bill please
support edik the one and also Mariah
Garcia please follow her on her YouTube
channel talk about it the video segment
she did with my so good make sure to go
check her out there and she has an
Instagram atwitter Twitter you know she
says stuff Instagram she post pictures
and stuff you know you know how it goes
you know the world of the socials and
the media's bye-bye